se eu estivesse começando hoje na área de dados
do zero, eu não faria o que eu fiz
e nem o que eu estava recomendando no ano passado
porque a grande verdade é que o jogo mudou
e não é só para quem está começando
se você é pleno, sênior, isso vale
para você também, pela primeira vez
o mercado deixou claro que você
precisa estudar duas coisas
em paralelo, tecnologia
e negócios, neste vídeo eu vou te mostrar
o roadmap que eu seguiria hoje
dependendo de onde você está hoje
eu não estou falando
isso por achismo, eu tenho conversado
com muitas empresas de segmentos diferentes
não é só startups, não
setor de papel celulose, mineração
agronegócio, empresas de serviço
e quando eu pergunto para os gestores
e diretores qual é a maior dificuldade
de contratar hoje, a resposta é
quase sempre a mesma, falta o profissional que tenha
duas habilidades ao mesmo tempo
tecnologia e negócios
alguém que consiga entender o porquê
construir e que saiba como
construir, e sabe quem está ocupando
essa vaga?
profissionais de negócio
que foram estudar tecnologia
e profissionais de tecnologia
que foram estudar negócio